je trouve la vidéo la vidéo alors si
vous êtes sur une démission la semaine
dernière on en a déjà fait 1 mais voyez
le mans vous étiez soit falla
alors je vais vous et non sur vous qui
avez trouvé le nom le trou des vidéos
non c'est valentin d'accord que je salue
quel producteur de l'émission en
compagnie de sasha qui l'assistent dans
cette lourde tâche ou alors êtes vous je
vous dis une phrase il ya un trou
donc écoutez bien écoutez bien la phrase
abate fait pas les malins parce que je
ne vous ai pas derrière deux vainqueurs
jolimont alors alors pendant une
séquence de kiss cam un homme refusant
voix c'est sa femme qui se fait trop
petit point par un taureau il se
plaignait en bois ces attaques aériennes
de sexuel en tournée enfourner enfin on
est chez encorné
par un taureau enfin tu l'as tirs
bousculée jacob de
remplacer revenons à ces c'est à
carcassonne
[Applaudissements]
fêtez les chicago bulls
là les rangs l'équipe évidemment c'est
presque de base offerts par un taureau
non mais par un prince charmant quoi
intriguer super merci pour cette belle
roma comment
s'il a reçu
il était nécessairement il est donc
n'étaient pas réveillé allez en numéro 2
pendant qu'un coupe s'embrouille sur le
balcon l'âme en profite pour s'enfuir en
tête et pointe à la saison quant aux
médias ce sont 400
vélos je crois que c'est bon gars et je
crois qu'elle a la bonne séance et en
slip je pense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
royal autre phrase pendant les vacances
pendant leur départ en vacances un homme
fait peur à sa femme en lui faisant
croire qu'elle va se prendre un melon
toro alors en plein plateau
1-1 quoi bateau un pédalo inconnu au
bataillon un jet ski à nabeul 1 encaissé
dix camions mois wet wet c'est un
caillou un camion pour l'amiante
vision l'image
un
homme fait un homme s'apprête à demander
sa copine en mariage quand tout à coup
lorsqu'il se décide de casser le délire
en faisant
ses vocations ou
[Musique]
exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
votre demande en mariage oui on en parle
dans le spectacle je te poses des vidéos
pour qu'ils gagnent la question et a
préparé sa femme que tu es préparer sa
liste mais dont j'ai préparé oui c'est
aux forces égales à bientôt pour tout ce
que j'ai eu le genou à terre et tout
autant que le club portugais quand
débarque à huis clos avec la bague je te
dire qu'à roissy comme j'avais la bac
dans le machin j'ai repris le mec je te
préviens si ton truc et ça ne suit que
des maths ah oui j'avais la balle
j'étudie rien hélas un de ses forces
alors ne sonne pas fait pas de l'or mais
on en est non si c'est la nature bois
ses gardes et s'est fait voir
l'or blanc l'ambiance est magnifique
j'ai jamais fait ce genre de deux
manches savage très romantique j'adore
mais je voulais savoir de la part
d'arnaud honnêtement si pépé sûr à 100%
qu'il ya 8 avec un petit doute quand
même il ya que le pourcentage de doute
il convient dans ce genre de situation
là je chante n'engendraient moins large
encore au mariage je te jure barrière et
un trac quant à l'église j'avais un trac
de dingo là j'étais à peu près sûr à
100% pour l'église ah oui oui vous avez
fait la mairie et on entrait
pour le premier
pas recommencer après
ménages dollar à 103 en
santé en leur nom
on a tous ces malades alors dernière
vidéo je ne sais pas où aller les uns
vidéo d'ailleurs d'entre eux qu e
valentin balante alors alors en sortant
de chez elle une femme glisse sur les
marches je n'ai heureusement son mari
arrivent et disent aussi à beaune
répondu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]